Je ne veux pas que vous pensiez que je suis là pour une œuvre de charité.
Je suis ici parce qu'il y a toujours un gros problème avec la manière
dont beaucoup de personnes perçoivent
les individus à déficiences intellectuelles,
ou, trop souvent,
la manière dont ils ne les voient pas du tout.
Saviez-vous que les championnats du monde s'étaient déroulés cette année ?
J'étais parmi les plus de 6 500 athlètes ayant des déficiences intellectuelles
venus de 165 pays et concourant à Los Angeles.
Il y avait plus de 62 000 spectateurs aux cérémonies d'ouverture,
et il y avait TSN et ESPN pour couvrir l'évènement.
Saviez-vous que cet événement s'était déroulé ?
Que pensez-vous lorsque vous rencontrez quelqu'un comme moi ?
Je suis ici aujourd'hui pour vous défier
de nous considérer comme égaux.
Les Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux transforment l'identité propre des athlètes
ayant des déficiences intellectuelles
et la perception de quiconque regardant la compétition.
Pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne le savent pas,
les Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux
s'adressent aux sportifs ayant des déficiences intellectuelles.
Les Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux sont séparés des Jeux Paralympiques et Olympiques.
Nous offrons des programmes sportifs de haute qualité, toute l'année
pour les personnes ayant des déficiences intellectuelles,
ce qui change des vies et la perception.
Ce mouvement a changé ma vie
et celle de tellement d'autres personnes.
Et cela a changé la manière
dont le monde voit les personnes ayant des déficiences intellectuelles.
Je suis né épileptique et avec une déficience intellectuelle.
En grandissant, j'ai joué au hockey jusqu'à mes 12 ans.
Plus je grandissais, plus je ressentais
qu'il était plus difficile de se maintenir à la hauteur des autres,
et j'étais énervé et frustré.
Pendant un certain temps, je n'ai plus pratiqué aucun sport,
n'avais plus aucun ami,
et me sentais oublié et triste.
Il fut un temps où les personnes ayant des déficiences intellectuelles
étaient cachées de la société.
Personne ne pensait qu'ils pouvaient pratiquer un sport,
et encore moins être un membre important pour la société.
Dans les années 60, Dr. Frank Hayden,
un scientifique à l'Université de Toronto,
étudiait les effets de l'exercice régulier
sur la condition physique des enfants ayant des déficiences intellectuelles.
Utilisant des recherches scientifiques rigoureuses,
Dr. Hayden et d'autres chercheurs
ont conclu
que c'était simplement le manque d'opportunité à participer
qui entraînait des problèmes de condition physique.
Beaucoup de gens doutaient
que les personnes ayant des déficience intellectuelles
pouvaient bénéficier des programmes de mise en forme
et des compétitions sportives.
Mais des pionniers comme Dr. Hayden et Eunice Kennedy Shriver,
le fondateur des Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux,
ont persévéré,
et les athlètes des Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux leur ont donné raison
quatre millions et demi de fois.
(Applaudissements)
Avant que je rejoigne les Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux,
j'étais nerveux
car j'étais jeune, timide, et avais peu de confiance en moi
et je n'avais pas beaucoup d'amis.
Lorsque je suis arrivé, pourtant, tout le monde m'a beaucoup encouragé,
m'a supporté et m'a laissé être moi-même
sans être jugé.
A présent, je suis un joueur de basketball et un patineur de vitesse
qui a concouru aux jeux régionaux, nationaux,
et cette année, a fini aux Jeux Mondiaux d’Été à Los Angeles,
où j'ai fait partie de la toute première équipe canadienne de basketball
à participer aux Jeux Mondiaux.
(Applaudissements)
Je suis l'un des plus de quatre millions et demi d'athlètes du monde entier,
et j'ai entendu tellement d'histoires similaires.
Être un athlète des Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux
redonne de la fierté et de la dignité.
Les Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux adressent également des besoins de santé importants.
Des études ont indiqué qu'en moyenne
les hommes ayant des déficiences intellectuelles
meurent 13 ans plus jeune que les hommes sans,
et les femmes ayant des déficiences intellectuelles
meurent 20 ans plus jeune que les femmes sans.
Le Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux nous gardent en bonne santé
en nous rendant actifs
et en nous faisant participer à un sport.
Par ailleurs, nos entraîneurs nous enseignent la nutrition et la santé.
Les Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux fournissent également des tests de dépistage gratuits
pour les athlètes qui ont des difficultés à communiquer avec leur docteur
ou à accéder aux soins médiaux.
Aux Jeux d’Été Mondiaux 2015,
mes coéquipiers de l'équipe Canada et moi jouions contre l'équipe du Nigeria.
Le jour précédent notre match,
l'équipe nigériane de basket était venue au dépistage
des Athlètes des Jeux Mondiaux
à l'occasion duquel des dispositifs d'aide auditive
ont été distribués gratuitement à sept membres sur dix
et ont eu l'occasion d'entendre clairement pour la première fois.
(Applaudissements)
Ce changement pour eux était incroyable.
Ils étaient très excités, contents et confiants,
car leurs entraîneurs pouvaient communiquer oralement avec eux.
Et ils étaient très émus
car ils pouvaient entendre les sons du ballon de basket,
les sons du sifflet
et les fans enthousiastes dans les tribunes —
des sons que nous tenons pour acquis.
Le Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux font plus que transformer les athlètes dans le sport.
Le Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux transforment leur vie en dehors des terrains.
Cette année, une recherche a démontré
que presque la moitié des adultes aux États-Unis
ne connaissent pas une seule personne ayant une déficience intellectuelle,
et les 44% des Américains
qui n'ont pas de contact personnel avec des déficiences intellectuelles
sont significativement moins tolérants et positifs.
Puis il y a le mot en « R »,
démontrant que les personnes ayant des déficiences intellectuelles
sont encore invisibles
pour beaucoup trop de monde.
Les gens l'utilisent comme un terme habituel ou une insulte.
Il a été tweeté plus de neuf millions de fois l'année dernière,
et c'est profondément blessant
pour moi et mes quatre millions et demi de camarades athlètes dans le monde.
Les gens ne s'imaginent pas que c'est insultant,
mais ça l'est.
Comme mon camarade athlète et porte-parole mondial John Franklin Stephens l'a écrit
dans une lettre ouverte à un commentateur politique
qui avait utilisé le mot en « R » comme insulte,
« Venez nous rejoindre un jour aux Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux.
Vous verrez si vous repartez avec le cœur inchangé. »
(Applaudissements)
Cette année, aux Jeux d’Été Mondiaux 2015,
les gens se sont alignés pendant des heures
avant de plonger dans la dernière nuit de compétition d'haltérophilie.
Cette soirée a fait salle comble lorsque mon coéquipier Jackie Barrett,
l’Élan de Terre-Neuve,
a soulevé 297 kg
et 277 kg en squats —
(Applaudissements)
établissant d'énormes nouveaux records aux Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux.
Jackie est l'un détenteur de record parmi tous les haltérophiles de Terre-Neuve —
pas seulement aux Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux mais tous les haltérophiles.
Jackie était une énorme célébrité à Los Angeles,
et ESPN a tweeté en direct son nouveau record
et était impressionné par sa performance.
Il y a 50 ans, peu de gens imaginaient des personnes déficientes mentales
capables de faire quelque chose comme ça.
Cette année, 60 000 spectateurs ont rempli le célèbre LA Memorial Coliseum
pour regarder les cérémonies d'ouverture des Jeux Mondiaux
et applaudir les athlètes de 165 pays
venant du monde entier.
Loin d'être cachés,
nous avons été applaudis et célébrés.
Les Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux apprennent aux athlètes
à être confiants et fiers d'eux-mêmes.
Les Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux apprennent au monde
que les gens ayant des déficiences intellectuelles
méritent le respect et la considération.
(Applaudissements)
A présent, j'ai des rêves et des succès dans mon sport,
des entraîneurs formidables,
du respect et de la dignité,
une meilleure santé,
et je poursuis une carrière d'entraîneur personnel.
(Applaudissements)
Je ne suis plus caché, moqué,
et je suis ici en train de donner une conférence TED.
(Applaudissements)
Le monde est un endroit différent grâce aux Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux,
mais il y a encore du travail.
Donc la prochaine fois que vous verrez
quelqu'un ayant des déficiences intellectuelles,
j'espère que vous verrez son talent.
La prochaine fois que quelqu'un utilise le mot en « R » à coté de vous,
j'espère que vous leur direz à quel point c'est blessant.
J'espère que vous songerez à vous impliquer
dans les Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux.
(Applaudissements)
J'aimerais vous quitter avec une toute dernière pensée.
Nelson Mandela disait :
« Le sport a le pouvoir de changer le monde. »
Les Jeux Olympiques Spéciaux changent le monde
en transformant quatre millions et demi d'athlètes
et en nous donnant un endroit où avoir confiance,
rencontrer des amis,
ne pas être jugés
et se sentir et être des champions.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)